[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
from iron chef america fame to abuse
allegations she wanted to get a
celebrity picture with the celebrity
chef the defendant but instead of just
selfies
the defendant began to grope miss tini's
body celebrity chef mario boutali stands
trial for sexual misconduct and the
disappearance of suzanne morphy i just
love my girls
and i love my wife
and i just want her to be found just
weeks after murder charges are dropped
barry morphew breaks his silence plus
johnny depp versus amber heard send me
right in the nose instantly
searing pain we take a closer look at
hurt's testimony and abuse allegations
but first the murder of georgia beauty
queen tara grinstead brian duke
confessed the evidence is going to show
that ryan admitted
that he had taken a narcotic
pain medicine
prior to that statement opening
statements are presented as ryan duke
stands trial for murder law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer more than
15 years after beloved beauty queen tara
grinstead went missing in her rural
georgia town accused killer ryan duke
stands trial for her murder on monday
opening statements were presented in the
case five years after duke was first
arrested investigators believe duke and
friend beau dukes are responsible for
grinstead's murder the pair are not
related but were both former students of
grinsteads after her disappearance in
2005 the case went cold for more than a
decade until duke and dukes were both
taken into custody in 2017. prosecutors
say ryan duke confessed to killing
grinstead saying he broke into her home
and killed her after a burglary went
wrong after that beau dukes helped burn
her body in a pecan orchard duke's
attorneys later said he was under the
influence of drugs during the confession
the famed podcast up and vanished is
credited with reigniting an interest in
gridstone's case some fans of the
podcast believe both dukes is
responsible for grinstead's murder in
2019 beau dukes was tried and found
guilty in connection to grinstead's
death in opening statements prosecutors
point to ryan duke's recorded confession
and the latex glove found on grinstead's
property that contained his dna
what about the glove we've talked about
i told you earlier we knew back in 2005
that tara grinstead's dna was on it as
well as
an unknown male
[Music]
1 2017
when ryan duke confesses
law enforcement also gets a sample of
his dna this is the first time he was
ever swapped in this case
and lo and behold
it's his
during the interview
agent chadel will ask him you'll hear it
now the dna on the glove is that going
to be yours and he says yes
[Music]
it should be
and it is
now there's a lot more details to this
glove
there's dna on the outside there's dna
on the inside
they re-swab it in 2015.
[Music]
but the bottom line with the glove is
the primary
contributor to the glove
of dna
is ryan dude
the defense countered an opening saying
grinstead's real killer is beau dukes
and now the 3d and that three dna
profiles can be found on the glove
this glove
that didn't appear until monday morning
the state cannot get bo duke's dna off
of that glove
you will hear evidence that they tried
you will hear evidence that they
talked with the gbi and tried to make
deviations and you'll hear all about it
but tried very hard
to change standards
to get bo duke's dna off of that glove
at best it was inconclusive what does
inconclusive mean
[Music]
you'll hear it means a weak match it
means they cannot get his dna off of
that glove
you'll also hear that that grub had at
least
three dna profiles on it
not two
at least three
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney karen nance and co-host terry
austin karen could duke's greatest
defense be pointing their finger at the
already convicted beau dukes
absolutely i think that with what we
just heard with uh dukes's attorney in
in her opening statement she's
opening the door to that doubt she's
presented several different factors that
she indicates that the prosecution can't
possibly overcome specifically with
regard to the glove and also
i think that we heard testimony today
about the character of both uh
mr beau dukes and ryan duke and i think
that um that's going to create some
doubt with the jury and i think that
there's a good chance he'll prevail yeah
i mean if an entire podcast following
this case some believe that i i think
there's at least enough to for the
defense to really sink their teeth into
terry is the dna on this glove as
important as the prosecution is making
it out to be in their opening statements
you know what brian dna is always
important it's often the key to whoever
committed the crime but during the
opening the prosecution only mentioned
those two profiles she said basically
there was tara grinstead and she said
brian duke she did not mention that
there was a third profile and you heard
the defense attorney there talk about
that i think the jury is going to wonder
whether or not the prosecution is hiding
something else and why wouldn't the
prosecution mention that there was this
third profile so i think we're going to
see a battle of the experts as far as
the dna is concerned and i think that is
going to be critical along with all of
the other evidence that we're going to
see in this trial but yes dna is going
to be critical yeah that inconclusive
thing makes me think that there is a
profile there but it's not conclusive
enough to say who it is or test it
against the other profiles it's going to
be interesting to see how both sides try
to argue that and show who is credible
here well thank you both for the update
on ryan duke from a georgia murder trial
to a manhunt in alabama as new details
emerge in the search for corrections
officer vicki white and inmate casey
white vicki white now faces new charges
stemming from an alias she used to
purchase an escape vehicle she's also
charged with permitting or facilitating
an escape this comes just days after an
suv believed to be the vehicle used in
the jail escape was recovered in a
tennessee tow lot last week the suv was
found abandoned in the woods without any
identifying information this after vicki
white a corrections officer and casey
white an inmate were reported missing
from lauderdale county jail in alabama
the two are not related but may be
involved in a romantic relationship on
april 29th vicki white took casey white
from the jail for a mental health
evaluation officials say she planned to
see a doctor after dropping off casey
white because she was not feeling well
after that the pair disappeared the
patrol car they used to leave the jail
was later found in a shopping center
parking lot inside the patrol car were
vicki white's jail keys radio and
handcuffs anyone with more information
is asked to contact their local
authorities
still ahead on law and crime daily the
family of suzanne morphy speaks out for
the first time since charges are dropped
against husband barry
but first it's johnny depp versus amber
heard we take a look back at herd's
intense direct examination
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
amber heard's testimony is put on a
week-long break as she faces off against
ex-husband johnny depp in a
multi-million dollar defamation lawsuit
the week-long break comes as part of a
pre-scheduled conference for fairfax
county judge penny azkarati court is
expected to resume on monday may 16th
the break comes amidst defendant amber
hurd's direct examination meaning debs
defense has an extra week to prepare for
cross-examination her testimony comes as
part of a defamation suit stemming from
her 2018 washington post op-ed about
domestic violence while depp was never
mentioned in the article he argues
readers know he was publicly linked to
heard depp filed a 50 million dollar
lawsuit against his ex-wife claiming
damages but heard shot back with a
hundred million dollar suit doubling
down on her domestic violence claims
last thursday she described an incident
when depp allegedly headbutt her before
she told him she was leaving him
oh you really want to go huh oh you're
so tough i stood back up again this time
he hits me in the face
i stand back up and look him right in
the eyes it was just a really still
moment i'll never forget it
really
still
i stood up and he said you want to go
again tough guy
and i just looked right at him just
looked right at his face
and he balled up his fist
leaned back
and head butted me square in the nose
just
right as i stood in front of him
i was
a foot from him
just
slam me right in the nose instantly
searing pain
so karen heard said she was headbutt a
foot away from death but depp says they
bumped heads as he tried to restrain her
so who is the jury to believe with these
two different stories
well that's the key right who is more
credible and not only with regard to
this specific incident but the entire
testimony from both heard and from
johnny depp i you can't split split the
baby you have to come up one side or the
other and i think that we haven't heard
all of the the direct examination of
amber heard so we're going to have to
wait to see what happens with her
further direct and also what's going to
happen when johnny depp's attorneys
cross-examine her to see if they can in
any way pull about her pull apart her
story yeah i always say that truth often
comes through cross-examination because
you can't prepare for that and that's
why they really dig into the facts terry
does herd's testimony make out that she
is a victim of domestic violence what do
you expect depp's lawyers to do with the
these accusations on cross
well listen herds team has a whole week
to prepare for costs but guess what so
does depths team and you better believe
me they're going to go through that
direct testimony and they are going to
parse it down they're going to pick the
number of issues they want to confront
and this december 15 2015 head butt
issue is one of the big issues they need
to
logically chronologically go through all
of her accusations and as far as this
one is concerned the issue here is where
were your injuries you said you broke
your nose did you go to the hospital
where was the blood we've heard dep talk
about there was no blood so i think
there's a lot to do as far as that issue
is concerned yeah ahead about from that
distance or someone's slightly taller
than you it's going to break the bridge
of your nose so i guess the question is
where's the corroboration and we'll see
how that plays out as you said direct
finishes and cross continues our starts
i guess thank you both coming up on lawn
crime daily a celebrity chef stands
trial on charges of sexual misconduct
plus two years after her disappearance
the family of suzanne morpheus speaks
out how they say prosecutors botched the
investigation
[Music]
welcome back we're hearing from the
family of suzanne murphy for the first
time since murder charges were dropped
against husband barry morphy
this comes two years after mother and
wife suzanne went missing on mother's
day 2020. her body has never been found
after her disappearance prosecutors
pointed the finger at husband berry
saying he discovered suzanne was having
an affair and murdered her after that
they say he tampered with evidence
morphe was set to stand trial earlier
this month for the crime but prosecutors
dropped charges in the 11th hour morphy
and his daughters had always maintained
he was not involved in suzanne's
disappearance in an exclusive good
morning america interview morphe and his
daughter broke their silence calling for
help to find suzanne and justice from
the prosecutors in the case
i just love my girls
and i love my wife
i just want her to be found it's been an
emotional roller coaster
but we feel like we can finally take our
first steps in healing which is
a blessing
and
yeah we
we just know our dad better than anyone
else
and we know he was not involved in our
mom's disappearance i just hope that
linda will
step up to the plate and
do everything she can to find our mom
because what they've done is not fair
terry his daughters believe he's
innocent so what's your reaction to
these charges being dismissed
i'm actually not surprised they were
dismissed without prejudice here listen
it turns out the prosecutors were
withholding some exculpatory evidence
that really could have helped the
husband you know obviously that's the
first person you're going to look when
you have a murder of a wife but if they
held back evidence and this was dna
evidence which could have pointed the
finger to someone else and that really
could have helped his defense so i think
it was the right move to dismiss the
case obviously they don't have a body
the judge really could have come down
even harder frankly and dismissed the
case himself with prejudice so we'll see
what happens but i think it's not
surprising that at this juncture they're
not going to pursue it yeah that sounds
like some brady violation or some
discovery violations maybe the judge
could have gone even further teaches
prosecutors how to properly handle the
case but karen that kind of brings us
back to the question of what next very
murphy's charges were dismissed without
prejudice and suzanne morphy's body
hasn't been found so could finding her
body bring new charges even for barry
yes and i believe that's what the
prosecution was alluding to they're
indicating that there's a lot of snow in
the area and they're waiting for for the
season to change so that they have an
opportunity to do a more extensive
search and the hope from the
prosecution's point of view is that if
they do find the body and they're
hopeful they've indicated it's been
reported that they are hopeful they'll
find the body can either
excuse
be exculpatory evidence for the husband
or
they can move forward with the
prosecution because as as terry
indicated it was without prejudice
meaning that they have that opportunity
to move forward the prosecution uh
provided that they have enough evidence
to do so yeah and here's hoping that
suzanne's body is found both for closure
for the family but also justice for
those
seeking it in this case
when we come back sexual assault
allegations against the top celebrity
chef ahead on law and crime daily
opening statements are presented in the
case of massachusetts versus mario
batelli
[Music]
welcome back opening statements are
presented after a quick start to a
sexual assault case where celebrity chef
mara batali faces a misdemeanor in
decent assault and battery charge in
boston
court got underway monday morning with
everyone expecting to begin jury
selection that changed once batali waved
his right to a jury trial asking that
the judge instead determined his fate
the chef well known in several
restaurant circles and from shows on
food network and abc's cooking show the
chew is accused of forcibly kissing and
groping natalie tini while taking a
selfie together in a boston restaurant
in 2017. batali pled not guilty to the
formal charges in 2019 once all
pre-trial business was finished
prosecutors presented their opening
statement telling the judge teenie snuck
a photo of the celebrity chef before
batali called her over to him
miss teeny stands there taking selfie
pictures with the defendant
but instead of just selfies
the defendant began to grope miss tini's
body
while he pulled her face
into his face kissing her with his left
hand
his right hand groped her breast her
butt
and her crotch area
miss teeny was confused she was shocked
she wasn't really sure what was going on
she noticed the descendant to be
drunk at that time
he couldn't really keep his eyes open in
the pictures he was slurring a bit and
he smelled like alcohol she walked away
almost immediately after but not before
the defendant invited her back to his
hotel that night
you're going to hear from miss teenie
herself she's going to tell you about
the pictures that she took
you're going to she's going to tell you
about what the pictures show
from about the shoulders up
and what's going on
below what you can see in the picture
the defendant groping her body
moments later battali's defense attorney
defended his client before the judge in
their opening statement saying the
victim's testimony is not credible
so there's two types of evidence in this
case we have the photos and the videos
that she took from the bar that night
those obviously are what they are
and they don't show an indecent assault
and battery and we're going to go
through them shortly
show you each one and we'll go through
it with her
the other kind of evidence you have is
miss tenny's
self-serving biased testimony
that she was assaulted
the evidence is going to show that she's
not credible
and that the photos and videos actually
contradict what she says happened eda
vinelli noted
what i would call the elephant in the
room which everyone sees and it's the
civil suit that's pending
she alleges severe and extreme emotional
distress
she says that it was
dehumanizing and humiliating what what
allegedly happened to her
those are the words in the complaint
that she filed that her lawyers filed
she has a financial motive to prevail in
this criminal case
and it's going to be borne out by the
evidence that i'm going to show you
karen why do you think batali opted out
of a jury trial is that a smart move in
a case like this
i think for
the defense perspective it is because
you don't have to worry about trying to
eliminate women from the jerk from the
jury pool that may be sympathetic to the
the victim in this case and so you just
had the case being heard by the judge
actually it's an exercise of judicial
economy because it's going to be a lot
quicker to try the case without picking
a jury so i'm sure that the
prosecution's happy about that and then
the judge also because there's other
core business to deal with but i think
that the idea is that let's hear it
before the one person that is uh sworn
to be non-biased and and not and sworn
to not have his emotions come into the
case whereas you don't have that promise
even though jurors indicate that they
would uh look at the case objectively so
i think from the defense perspective it
is a good move yeah that makes sense
based on these types of sexual assault
cases especially misdemeanors terry who
had the strongest opening statement in
your opinion
i actually thought both of the opening
statements were very strong the
prosecution was extremely detailed
giving all of the information that we're
going to hear at the trial as far as the
actual assault was concerned but i
thought the defense was good too they
simply said look it didn't happen we're
going to show you videos we're going to
show you photographs and if they
actually have other witnesses to
cooperate what their story is i think
they're going to have a good story it
really comes down to that he said she
said as we've seen in these types of
cases before and so whatever other
additional information i think that's
going to be key here and that
credibility that motive why she's
bringing this she's bringing both the
civil case and the criminal case so
we'll see what happens yeah it's a lot
easier because it's only one incidence
of sexual assault or misconduct so it
should be easy for both sides to attack
well karen and terry thank you very much
and thank you for joining us here at law
on crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you